did you know Intel processors brought
personal computers to the home
totally and then Intel made them more
efficient so that you could fit all this
into a laptop tight real tight and then
they help bring Wi-Fi to everybody and
now Intel's best processor ever is here
which helps pcs do things you never
thought possible like time travel Hey
these pants are timeless introducing
Intel's new 6th generation Core
processor it's our best processor ever
biomimicry is innovation inspired by
nature it's learning from and then
emulating nature's best ideas we're
already living with lot of biomimetic
technologies and if you use Velcro
velcro comes from an inventor who took a
hike with his dog George minstrel when
he got back home he realized that there
were seeds burrs stuck to the hair and
he realized wow this is a really good
design if you want to send something and
he looked at the burr under the
microscope and he realized that it had
tiny hooks and so he invented this
two-sided velcro
one with loops and one with hooks so
biomimicry is all around us already
radar was invented by looking at how
organisms like bats put out a sound and
then they're able to almost see by
reading those echoes if you go through
an airport and you go through one of
those millimeter scanners that's based
on a bat called the Brazilian
free-tailed bat it's so precise that it
allows this acoustic camera to see
through clothing
I see biomimicry as a way that we can
leapfrog towards a much more sustainable
world we've got a lot of problems to
solve biomimicry helps you look into the
natural world where they may have
already been solved in a really elegant
way for more episodes of things like a
tree subscribe to the wired Channel